- Welcome back, I couldn't
begin this journey
without two women who have
been a part of my heart
for over 20 years.
We are friends, we are fellow Angels.
Please welcome my partners
in crime and life,
Lucy Liu and Cameron Diaz.
(audience cheers)
(funky music)
(women shrieking)
(Cameron laughs)
Oh my God, you guys!
This is the loudest this room has been!
(women laughing)
First, I sent Cameron a video
and I'm saying, "Hey, listen,
I wanna ask you something.
"Will you come on the show?"
I've never done this in my life.
Because I'm so comfortable,
I mean, we have lived
together all over the world,
so of course, to save time,
I sent her a video while
I'm getting dressed.
(Cameron and Lucy laughing)
And you don't see anything.
I'm not that dumb, but I'm
getting out of the shower
and I'm wringing out of my towel.
And I don't hear back
from her for two days,
and I'm like, "This is weird.
"Did I, what is going on?"
So I text her and I'm like, "I don't care
"about the question, are you okay?
I don't hear again for two
days and I'm freaking out.
So I call her and I'm
like, "What is going on?
"I'm worried, is everything okay?"
She's like, "I don't know
what you're talking about."
I'm like, "The video,
you didn't get my video?"
Turns out, a young boy got the video.
(audience laughs)
- Lucky him!
- [Drew] Oh, no.
- Oh, no, by the way,
it's seven minutes long.
- Oh my God!
(women laughing)
- It's epic, I mean,
this is some material.
- So many secrets revealed.
- This kid's gonna have this material.
Honestly, this is gonna last
him three or four years.
(women laugh)
- I'm really hamming it up because it's--
- 'Cause it's you?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it was good.
I was like, "Send me
that video immediately.
"I need to know what is in that video,"
and the whole while, I'm just cracking up
because it's just--
- You need to send me
this video as well, or do
it through someone else,
because I didn't get
your other video, either.
- So then--
- Someone said,
- I sent--
- "Did you get her video?"
I was like, "No."
- No, something's wrong with my phone.
So I sent Lucy this video, crying,
inviting her on the show,
saying--
- In her bathroom, crying.
- I am in my bathroom.
- She was dressed.
(Cameron and Lucy laugh)
- I was fully clothed
this time, I didn't take the risk,
and she didn't get the video, either!
(audience laughs)
- Come on.
- I know, I know.
The thing that I love about our friendship
is that we have been there
in all the big and important moments.
We've also been there in the small moments
and the casual moments.
And the reason we are such good
friends is because it's real
and we go through real
stuff with each other.
It's not a Hollywood fairytale.